all right the media mob is largely
ignored what is a growing disaster in
Ohio which started after a train
carrying hazardous materials derailed
near the Ohio Pennsylvania border in
East Palestine Ohio that prompted an
evacuation order for nearby residents
and controlled burning as you can see of
the remaining chemicals now tonight the
environmental concerns are growing
prompting water utility companies to
take precautions now while reports are
of all over the place about animals
falling sick and dying or circulating
well here with more is Ohio Congressman
Bill Johnson he represents the district
and was at the scene earlier today
I've seen pictures of dead fish of of
dead animals people talking about you
know they don't believe the water's safe
how bad is this and what is the federal
government done to help you
yeah Sean I was there I had boots on the
ground there earlier today and and
you're exactly right the primary concern
the number one priority is the uh is the
quality of the air the the water uh and
the Safety and Security of the people
that live there uh look I I haven't seen
myself I didn't see any dead animals uh
I was told that there were some dead
fish that uh that were in a nearby
um uh shorter uh water spot and I was
also told that there were some uh foxes
that had not been evacuated that uh that
perished as well uh so I'm not certain
about that but I can tell you that from
what I saw today the site is largely
cleaned up the uh uh and and there's
more cleanup to do the EPA has sampled
and continues to sample the air quality
they've done two
285 plus home air tests they've got 185
more scheduled they're testing the water
around the clock uh and and you can
better believe I'm going to be asking
questions to make sure that we continue
that until we're 100 sure that uh that
we've really mitigated this problem all
right Congressman keep us in the loop
our prayers are with the people in your
district and Community thank you sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else